how are y'all doing out there Aaron
Sampson here with Ryan Schubert and if
you know us you know we'd like to talk
about tactical shooters there's a lot of
shooters coming out this upcoming
quarter well I guess the beating in next
quarter we're looking at a battle feel
the call of duty on the horizon right
you get the big ones coming up but we'd
like to give some time to some of the
smaller titles particularly the ones
that lean a little bit more tactical
like the armas the dragon risings out
there so in that note we had a chance to
check out insurgencies sandstorm
insurgency was released oh god 2015 and
sandstorm just sort of refines that game
so it's large maps but close quarters
bigger maps but still close quarters
like how would you place those like
within like comparison to Call of Duty
and Battlefield you know maybe team
deathmatch and caught in battlefield
would be about the size of the map but
plenty of routes through the map which I
really enjoyed so the best we can
describe this game though is as if
somebody took the war tapes audio
setting from battlefield and made a game
around it because oh my god does this
game sound just scary and chaotic
you remember war tapes oh yeah for sure
I mean that was the way to go if you're
wearing headphones and playing
battlefield it's just like the raw input
of the audio without much mixing going
on so for example rocket-propelled
grenades they like Louise Buy and all
the explosions are not Hollywood
explosions they're they feel realistic
they have those like little sparks and
like the a-10 gun runs that that sound
that an a tent that burping sounded at
AJ that's when it comes by
and grenades you know they don't it's
not this like comical fiery explosion
it's that just like the throwing sparks
and then things just drop right
I can't understate how good the chaotic
sounds of war are in this game okay so
you were saying also that there were
some interesting ammo mechanics that we
don't usually get in more common
first-person shooters
yeah and a lot of first-person shooters
don't really do ammo jumping they just
sort of combine they're edible
yeah at all I don't know what it fits or
not into some games but in this game so
here's how it works
when you're running out of ammo you can
tap R once and you'll stow the ammo back
on your person with however many bullets
are in the magazine only to pull that
back out later and try and like you'll
default whichever magazine has the most
ammo but suddenly like in a game like
this and we're playing co-op here you
and there's a PvP mode as well but it
really makes you stop and like try and
figure out how much ammo you have on
your person before entering a building
or in an emergency you can double tap R
and drop your ammo to the ground but you
lose that ammo and I think I only had
like five mags or something like that
maybe even less you drop that is it gone
gone it's all in the ground I don't
remember if you can pick it back up or
not but it's all of a sudden it's
something you really have to think about
and it's not gimmicky like I feel like
ammo dumpings been used as a gimmick in
some games in this game I ran into a
building and realize that hadn't
properly managed my like clips
isn't that like compulsive reloading
thing everybody does and just barely
pulled out not dying with a secondary
which I'll show here a little bit later
that's really cool I mean I always like
seeing ammo management and part of a
tactical shooter because it it really
just heightens tension so you were
telling me that this isn't just strictly
person-to-person combat that there's
also an element that involves air
strikes or a commander and an observer
so it's class-based and there's a
commander and an observer and if you
look in the lower left corner here those
two icons have are the commander in the
observer and they have to stay within a
certain proximity of each other
to call in an airstrike so the observer
just has to physically be present to
call it in it's really cool too because
you hear them call it out in person but
you also hear it over the radio so if
you're at sort of a medium distance away
from the person you hear them call it on
the radio but then you're also on the
radio so when they're together they can
do things like call in an a-10 gun run
an Apache hell fire strike the
insurgents have some stuff that's been
inspired by recent events like they can
call in drones with bombs on them and
like some stuff that like when you hear
it it makes you stop and look up okay so
it's somewhat balanced in that respect
yeah so both sides get it there's no
unlock tree in this so it's class-based
but you have about 15 points to spend
it's kind of like the pick ten system to
pick 15 point system one of the big
things they talked about and and you
know developers don't want to divide
their communities so it's weird actually
I don't know how to feel about this this
game doesn't even have an unlock tree
everything's just there it's all
class-based and the only thing they're
talking about in the future may be that
you'll unlock and maybe they'll sell you
in the future as Cosmetics and are like
how do you feel about games that don't
have unlock trees I have to say that I'm
kind of over unlocked trees at this
point I mean I like I like unlocking
things but I also find it frustrating
sometimes when you know like if we go
all the way back to you know when we
used to play like battlefield 3 and it
was like there's a very linear unlock
pattern of attachments for every weapon
and you know from experience playing the
game you could usually pick up a weapon
you knew exactly what you wanted to put
on it but you also knew that you needed
to get like 300 kills with it before you
could use that uh that attachment that
drove me crazy
and it would force you to do things that
were counter to the objectives like a
lot of times what you had to do to
unlock a weapon wasn't fun or as grindy
or it made you play dumb like oh yeah I
mean the objective based unlocks were
always obnoxious because yeah usually
would encourage you not to do like
though the the one that always bothered
me was the
and battlefield 3 you had to wound a
certain number of people with an LMG
without actually killing them like how
does that even work you're just like
whoa whoa whoa I'm not gonna kill you
all the way we please don't kill me and
I can't kill you but like having to
resist the instinct to do the right
thing in this situation yeah yeah so
just to reiterate this game does not
have anything that would divide the
community down the line that they're
talking about now it doesn't have an
unlock tree so you're just playing for
the joy of it and you are the weapons
are definitely based on the classes in
the game yeah like I don't know unlock
trees are addictive but also I think
there's something to be said for just
the enjoying a game because you enjoy it
I mean that's I think what works best
about some games like siege for example
or it's like I mean obviously there's an
unlock system but if you know if you
bought the game at a certain level you
have all of the operators and you don't
need to worry about spending time trying
to get exactly everything the way you
want it you just figure it out and roll
this game has some stiff competition
with the window it's releasing in but
I'm definitely looking forward to
playing more of the beta which runs
through August 13th the release date for
insurgency Sam's forum is September 18th
so if you're if you're over your Call of
Duty's in your battlefields definitely
feel free to check it out and with that
I'll leave you with a little bit of
ending gameplay here so you can hear
what I'm talking about
[Music]
okay let me low